we're so mean to ourselves so utterly
barbarically cruel if we saw someone
treating a stranger the way we tend to
treat ourselves we'd be appalled we need
to learn to be that most rare of things
a proper friend to ourselves to be our
own best friend it doesn't come
naturally we need to practice saying
some of the following to ourselves
you deserve to exist it's okay to make
mistakes you can be forgiven I know how
hard you try and all the obstacles
you've had to overcome
I don't care what the others think you
can be weak with me you can mess up you
can fall apart you can be imperfect you
can let me down I'm on your side I'm
touched by how much efforts you have
made and how deeply you have suffered
you don't have to prove yourself to me I
don't need you to be somebody I can love
you as you are despite everything I'm
your best friend always and I'm right
here
small pleasures guides us around the
best of life's overlooked or
underestimated pleasures to find out
more follow the link on your screen now
you